- All right everybody,
we've reached the point
where I share something to bring you joy
from the world of social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
This story starts with the Compton woman
who completely turned her life around.
She had her first child
at 15 and another at 19,
and ended up relying on welfare,
but it wasn't the life she'd hoped for,
so she made some changes.
Thank goodness because 30 years later,
she's a registered nurse who
served on the front lines
in the battle against COVID.
She even went to help in
New York for a few months
and now she's back in
L.A. taking to the streets
to provide her neighbors with resources,
to not only prevent coronavirus,
but to live their healthiest lives.
From Street Love, please
everybody welcome Shannon.
(audience cheers)
I love your dress or your
top, whatever that is,
that's beautiful, I love your outfit.
- Thank you for having me on your show.
- No absolutely, we're so
happy that you're here.
So Shannon, this is an
amazing turnaround story.
Why did you want to be a nurse?
- Well it started when I had
my first son at the age of 15
and I had a mentor,
who to today we are
still very good friends.
She was a registered nurse
and she taught our nursing program
that coupled with my nurturing spirit,
it was destined to be.
- That's amazing.
Well thank you so much, first of all,
for everything that you did on
the front lines for all of us
and are still doing, thank you so much.
(audience applause)
So tell us what Street
Love does for communities
in Los Angeles.
- Well I started Street
Love after coming back
from New York working on the
front line with the COVID
and seeing the real
need of how the disease
impacted people that had co-morbidities
and it was very important
for me to give back
to the communities,
such as Compton and Watts and Carson
and other Los Angeles areas.
And we go in and give the
health and wellness message,
as well as give health
and wellness resources,
such as wellness boxes,
blood pressure cuffs,
wellness journals, all
different types of things.
We educated on COVID and
hand hygiene and face masks
and our goal is to take this
not only from city to city,
in California, but state to state.
- That's amazing.
Well thank you so much for
everything you're doing Shannon.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience applause)
- Thank you so much for
having me, I love your show.
- Oh, thank you so much,
but hey, that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
that go-to pen at "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers, just like you ma'am.
So they'll be using their G2 gel ink pen
to write you a check for
$1,000 How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my god.